in 1946 one of the most significant and
groundbreaking archaeological
discoveries of the 20th century was made
near the Dead Sea documents and ancient
text were found in caves in this region
these came to be given the name the Dead
Sea Scrolls an amazing collection
including some of the earliest examples
of biblical scriptures we have as well
as other texts not included in the
biblical Canon that shed light on
religion in Judea around the turn of the
Common Era the authors or at least
owners of these texts who lived in a
nearby community in qumran are often
identified as the so-called essines a
mysterious Jewish sect that is mentioned
in several ancient sources but who were
these essenes and what are their
connection if any to the Dead Sea
Scrolls and the qumran community
[Applause]
ancient Judaism looked quite different
from the religion as we know it today
rabbinic Judaism only started to form
essentially after the destruction of the
second temple in the year 70 A.D and
before this there existed many different
groups of Jews who approached and
understood the religion in various
different ways this is true today too of
course but the differences back then
between these groups are arguably even
more fundamental around the turn of the
Common Era and in the few centuries
before most of Judaism was centered in
the lands of Judea and Israel and in
particular around the city of Jerusalem
where the Great temple stood
for this reason we find reference to
different groups of Jews in the New
Testament and gospel accounts there are
of course the Pharisees who show up to
challenge Jesus in the gospels as well
as the sadokies where the Priestly and
upper class associated with the
maintenance of the Temple but in ancient
accounts we also find references to
other groups the famous first century
Jewish writer and historian flavius
Josephus wrote a book called The Jewish
war in which it describes three main
sects of Judaism at the time
quote indeed there exists among the Jews
three schools of philosophy the
Pharisees belong to the first The
Saturdays to the second and to the third
belong men who have a reputation for
cultivating a particularly saintly life
called essines
so who are these scenes they appear to
have been a significant community in
Antiquity but essentially died out
around the time that Josephus was riding
well this group in fact remains rather
mysterious even to this day and we don't
have a lot of material to work with or
do we we'll return to the question of
qumran later which might be a decisive
Factor here but in terms of information
about the essenes their beliefs and
practices we are limited to a few
historical sources in particular there
are three ancient writers that mention
or describe this essene community the
already mentioned Josephus there is
Philo of Alexandria the Great platonist
Jewish philosopher of the first century
and Pliny the Elder a famous Roman
natural philosopher so what do these
accounts have to say about these scenes
well the essenes appear to have been a
strongly you could say ascetic Community
they seem to have been spread out across
Judea but lived primarily in villages
and smaller communities avoiding cities
probably to remain pure and untainted by
the worldliness and faulty practices of
City dwellers Philo suggests that at the
time that he wrote his every good man is
free there were around 4 000 essenes
living in this region
these scenes are described as a
community that took the Jewish law very
seriously like unusually seriously they
lived a very strict life centered on
worship and ritual purity when you
became part of the community you gave up
all your possessions and all goods were
basically the property of the community
as a whole
there was a hierarchy with managers on
top and new initiates at the bottom to
become part of the community you had to
go through a long process of several
years of study before earning your place
some scenes seem to have lived in closed
off communities such as perhaps in Quran
whereas we saw all property belonged to
the group as a whole the regular day was
spent in prayer and study of the Hebrew
scriptures as well as strictly regulated
daily communal meals
there was also a huge emphasis on ritual
Purity where the members would regularly
purify themselves in water so bathing
essentially when not praying they would
work primarily with agriculture except
of course on the Sabbath which was
observed with extreme strictness no work
was permitted and this included things
like lighting a fire or just carrying an
object it seems that these scenes were
primarily a male community and that they
might have lived in celibacy shunning
all forms of romantic relationships to
instead focus on Strictly following the
Jewish law however Josephus reports that
some machines did allow marriage and
that sex was allowed within the context
of that marriage but absolutely
forbidden outside of that particular
context so sex was only meant to create
new children for procreation but was
forbidden for any other circumstance as
for their beliefs they were Jews
obviously so they followed the Torah and
the Hebrew Bible in general as well as
possibly some extra biblical material if
there is indeed a connection with the
Dead Sea Scrolls these scenes appear to
have been influenced by or been a part
of what is known as Jewish
apocalypticism a theological movement
popular at around this time which
introduced some new and unique features
to the religion for example this can be
seen in the fact that the essenes
believed that the human soul was eternal
and Immortal but it had become trapped
or attached to the human body but would
survive after its demise furthermore
they believed that the afterlife was a
spiritual one and not physical that the
soul was subject to a judgment by God
after death and that those who were good
in this life would be rewarded with a
pleasant spiritual afterlife while those
who were Wicked would be punished and
face terrible retribution after death
these ideas which had become common in
Jewish thought in late Antiquity would
of course come to serve as Central
aspects of Christianity and Islam too if
these ancient literary courses can be
trusted then we seem to know quite a bit
about these scenes and their general
characteristics but do we have anything
from these scenes themselves in terms of
writings well this is where we get back
to that original question which is what
is if any the connection between these
scenes and the so-called Dead Sea
Scrolls the Dead Sea Scrolls were an
amazing archaeological find back in the
mid 20th century there are many
legendary stories surrounding their
Discovery but the common narrative is
the two Bedouin Shepards stumbled upon a
cave near qumran in which they found
several Scrolls stored in jars this
discovery which took place between 1946
to 1947 would pass through many hands as
it gradually became clear that this was
a rather significant find in the
following years and decades more and
more caves were found in this area which
contained similar Scrolls this is an
incredibly fascinating thing and it's
still ongoing as recently as last year
in 2021 there were more fragments
discovered in similar conditions in the
region so this is a region that has
contributed with some really significant
archaeological materials since the
initial Discovery so what are these Dead
Sea Scrolls what is in them the Scrolls
which many scholars today prefer to call
the qumran Scrolls contain fragments
from many different kinds of texts
some of these fragments are full Scrolls
containing entire books from the Bible
While others are tiny fragments of
parchment of only a few words or so the
majority of these texts are biblical
copies of the books of the Hebrew Bible
and commentaries or other texts related
to the books of the Hebrew Bible in fact
about a quarter of the scrolls are
simply well books from the Hebrew Bible
but this is still very significant
because this makes them some of the
earliest copies of the Bible before the
discovery of the Scrolls the oldest
manuscripts of the Bible we had were
basically from the 9th to 10th Century
here instead we now have examples of
those same texts but from way earlier
from the turn of the Common Era and
maybe even from the first few centuries
BC it's also significant of course that
these Scrolls include slightly altered
versions of these biblical texts before
the so-called masoretic text became
standardized around 180 there were
different variations of the biblical
text that circulated it was always a
fluid collection of text and defines at
qumran reflect this now most of the
differences from The Standard Bible are
very minor but it's still very
significant from a historical point of
view aside from these standard books
from the Hebrew Bible the Scrolls also
included what is known as Apocrypha and
suit epigrapha in other words books that
are not included in most versions of the
biblical Canon the Apocrypha include
books that are only part of the Catholic
Old Testament but not the Hebrew Tanakh
or the Protestant Bible such as the book
of Tobin secondly the pseud epigrapha
include books that are not part of any
Bible basically it is here that we find
texts like the famous and Incredibly
fascinating books of Enoch and the Book
of jubilees then there are works that
are often deemed sectarian Works in
other words text that were written by
and for a specific community in this
case probably the community living in
qumran and which gives us details about
their beliefs and practices these
include texts like the so-called
Community rule the Damascus documents
and the so-called War scroll and then
there are a bunch of commentaries on and
shorter summaries of biblical books as
well so as you can see the qumran
Scrolls include a lot of different books
and different kinds of books many of
these are the biblical books that we all
know and love but others are unfamiliar
to most the books of Enoch for example
has become famous for their strange
stories about the Watchers and this
would require a whole separate episode
to cover properly nonetheless these
qumran or Dead Sea Scrolls are probably
the most significant archaeological
discovery of the 20th century that has
revolutionized our understanding of
second temple Judaism and the New
Testament period in in this region of
the world but who were the people that
wrote them or who owned them and
presumably hid them in these caves as we
said the caves in which the Scrolls were
found were all located around a place
called qumran today an archaeological
site that seems to have been the
settlement of a peculiar Community a
community of Jews who lived rather
strict lives dedicated to the observance
of Jewish law we know of this Quran
Unity both from the actual site at
qumran but also in texts like the
community Rule and the war scroll that
seem to detail the way that they lived
and some of what they believed the
qumran community and the larger sect
that they belong to seem to have broken
off from the other groups of Jews that
were centered around the temple in
Jerusalem they believed that the temple
had been taken over by false priests and
rejected the temple cult in Jerusalem
instead choosing to gather in places of
their own where they could follow their
strict interpretation of the law in the
words of the archaeologist Jody Magnus
quote qumran was occupied by members of
a wider movement that separated from the
rest of the Jews in Judea around the
middle of the second century BCE or
earlier over differences in the
interpretation and practice of Jewish
law
in general this sect was stricter in its
interpretation of Jewish law than other
Jews it seems like they believe that the
cult in the Jerusalem Temple were
performed incorrectly and that the law
wasn't followed properly so they instead
formed a strongly hierarchical community
of their own centered on Priests of the
zadokaid lineage which had led the
Templar practices in Jerusalem
previously membership was limited to
adult males who were deemed worthy and
the initiation process seemed to have
been long taken years
our sources also suggest that once one
became a member you had to give up at
least a portion of your possessions to
the community as a whole as we saw the
qumran community seems to be only one
settlement of a larger movement or
Community across Judea archeology
suggest that there were probably around
150 to 200 people living in the
settlement at any given time and from
texts like the community rule it also
seems like this might have been an
especially strict environment
members of The Wider Community could be
married and have kids but the group in
qumran in particular appeared to have
lived a life of celibacy
their lives were governed by a very
strict code of conduct being very
meticulous to follow every aspect of the
Jewish law and harsh punishments for
those who didn't members could be
excommunicated for failing to follow the
rules properly or be punished for what
we would consider very minor things for
example the Damascus document states
that if a person accidentally fell
asleep during a communal meeting they
would be expelled for 30 days and had to
do Penance for 10 days on top of that
one of the more Central aspects of their
daily lives included communal meals as
well as a very strong emphasis on ritual
Purity indeed the archaeological site at
qumran contains several so-called
mikvahs or baths where the members would
purify themselves on a regular basis
this emphasis on ritual Purity seems to
have been especially important to the
Quran Community not only based on the
existence of these mikbot bats but also
on their beliefs and their view of
themselves based on these texts indeed
the community appears to have seen
itself as a kind of substitute for the
temple in Jerusalem again in the words
of Jody Magnus Court
in other words the sectarians conducted
their lives as if the community was a
virtual Temple or Tabernacle for this
reason they observed the same strict
regulations governing Purity including
immersion and purity of food drink and
dishes as those required for the temple
cult instead of the daily sacrifices in
the temple of Jerusalem the qumran
community replaced this with two daily
prayers that everyone performed even
though sacrifices also seem to have
taken place the community was the temple
a replacement of the now defunct Temple
until the future Redemption when
Jerusalem would be ruled by the true
priests again we thus find a community
that thought very highly of themselves
they were the real Israel and the only
ones who were following the law properly
the end times were very close as
indicated from the sectarian Scrolls and
they were at the verge of a new
Messianic era in which they represented
the sons of Light and all others were
the so-called Sun of Darkness these
forces would engage in a 40-year war in
which the sons of Light would eventually
win drive out the Romans and
re-establish true worship in the
Jerusalem Temple the war also had Cosmic
significance in which the Earthly war
was mirrored in a cosmic war between the
forces of Good and Evil represented by
angels and the Demonic forces of Satan
in other words the Quran Community
definitely belonged to the wider
movement of antiquity known as Jewish
apocalypticism which we mentioned
earlier
all of these ideas are found in the
sectarian Scrolls found in the cave
surrounding the Quran site which
explains the origins current practices
and future predictions that they had of
themselves in terms of practices they as
we have said follow the laws of the
Torah with an unusual strictness as well
as emphasize rituals of Purity in the
Mikvah baths and communal dining
another thing that made the qumran
community stand out is the fact that
they used a solar calendar rather than
the moon calendar of the other Jews this
meant that the different sacred days of
the year would fall on different dates
than for the rest of the Jews which for
those members of the sector lived in
larger Villages and towns would probably
create some tensions with their
neighbors this was also a very
hierarchical Community the priests ruled
Supreme and had full power the group had
a highest Authority called the mebaker
the guardian also called the master who
presided over the community taught them
how to conform to the law and in general
supervised the whole sect as for the
origins of the sect we have only a few
hints in the Damascus document we find
reference to the founder of the sect as
someone called the teacher of
righteousness a person who had a proper
understanding of the Torah and could
guide the community to counter all the
things that the Jerusalem Israelites had
misunderstood or done wrong this
person's action identity from a
historical perspective isn't known since
he is hidden behind this nickname and
there are other such Anonymous figures
mentioned in the Scrolls that appear
important such as the so-called Wicked
priest the sprouter of lies and the
kitten with the exception of the last
term kitim which most Scholars agree
probably refers to the Romans there is
no consensus on who all of these figures
are
the wicked priest and spouter of Lies
probably refers to some figures
associated with the Jerusalem clergy
possibly Jonathan maccabeus a key figure
of the maccabean revolt and a leader of
the hasmonian dynasty that ruled Judea
but Scholars disagree on these questions
it seems relatively clear that they at
least represent the enemies of these
scenes namely the other sects of Judaism
at the time the Pharisees and the
sadokies As for the so-called teacher of
righteousness there have been many
theories of all kinds he has been
identified sometimes with John the
Baptist with Jesus himself James the
just and much more all of these theories
are generally rejected by Scholars today
though the only indication we have is
that the term righteousness zedek in
Hebrew seems to refer to the zadokite
lineage of priests who lost Monopoly
over the temple after the maccabean
Revolt it is thus possible that the
community that the qumran group belonged
to was founded by priests of the
zadokite lineage who consider the new
clergy in Jerusalem to be illegitimate
and this kind of leads us to the million
dollar question were the qumran
community essenes
many scholars probably the majority of
Scholars historians today argued that
they indeed were you may have noticed
that the descriptions of these scenes in
the ancient writers like Josephus and
Philo is very similar to the ideas and
practices of the Quran Community a very
strict adherence to the law an emphasis
on ritual Purity communal meals
selective celibacy and much else there
is so much fascinating stuff when it
comes to the beliefs of the Quran
community so I've actually turned to an
expert who's going to tell you even more
about a particular aspect of their
theology namely Dr Andrew Henry from the
channel religion for breakfast
thanks Phillip another reason why many
scholars believe that the qumran
community and the essenes are one and
the same is because of Fate what do I
mean by that in a passage comparing the
Sadducees Pharisees and essenes Josephus
says that the essenes were somewhat
skeptical of free will he says the
essenes declare that fate is the
Mistress of all things and that nothing
befalls people unless it is in
accordance with her decree by comparison
the Sadducees completely reject fate and
emphasize that humans have Free Will and
the Pharisees take a middle position we
can call the essene theological position
on fate a strong sense of predeterminism
my Dead Sea Scrolls professor in
graduate school Jonathan clawans even
joked that the essenes were the
Calvinists of second temple Judaism
holding to the theological position of
predestination in other words the
essenes believed in God's absolute
foreknowledge of and control over future
events and Lead toward the denial of
free choice
possible Parallels for this strong
predeterminism have been found in the
Dead Sea Scrolls for example in the
sectarian document called the community
rule we find what Dr clawans calls the
clearest articulation of predestination
in all of ancient Jewish literature from
the god of knowledge comes all that is
and shall be before ever they existed he
established their whole design and when
as ordained for them they came into
being it is in accordance with his
glorious design that they accomplished
their task without change the text goes
on to say that God has ordained the
righteous to walk in the ways of the
light and the evil to walk in the ways
of Darkness this is predestination so
this may be more evidence that the
kunran community was an essene Community
but not all Scholars agree Josephus
seems to be describing an idea of Fate
influenced by Greek philosophy he
doesn't seem to know about the qumran
idea of predestination that is more
dualistic but the similarities remain
and can't be ignored back to you Philip
thank you Andrew and please everyone
check out his amazing work over at
religion for breakfast
Philo suggested that there were around 4
000 essenes living in Judea and that
they were spread out into different
communities it seems to many that qumran
was one such Community furthermore one
of the most suggestive pieces of
evidence comes from that third Source on
the essenes Pliny the Elder
he writes quote they these scenes are a
people unique of its kind and admirable
beyond all others in the whole world
without women and renouncing love
entirely without money and having
company only the palm trees below these
scenes was the town of engedi which
yielded only to Jerusalem in fertility
and palm gropes but has today become
another Ash Heap
from there one comes to the Fortress of
Masada
Pliny here seems to geographically place
an essene settlement north of Masada and
engetti along the Dead Sea which is
exactly where we find qumran these
points have led many scholars to
conclude that the Quran Community indeed
represents a group of essenes it should
be pointed out though that there is no
consensus on this matter many scholars
are still skeptical of this connection
due to lack of any clear evidence right
so the discussion is still ongoing
Scholars will disagree but I would say
that most Scholars today accept this
connection between the qumran community
and the essenes in any case if we accept
this connection this indeed seems to
indicate that it was the essenes that
wrote The Dead Sea Scrolls where at the
very least that these squirrels belonged
to that Community much of what we know
about the essenes does seem to be
confirmed they were a unique sect of
Judaism separated from groups like the
Pharisees and sadokies who lived around
Judea and gathered in communities like
qumran led by a Priestly class and
Guardians who had absolute Authority
they saw themselves as a kind of
placeholder Temple since the one in
Jerusalem had been corrupted and
followed a very strict observance of the
law as well as practices of communal
dining and purification baths these
scenes also clearly were influenced by
the apocalyptic Jewish literature and
held strong beliefs that the end of days
was approaching that the dead would be
resurrected and that there would be a
judgment from God a judgment where they
believed that they the so-called sons of
Light were the only winners while they
appeared to have played a major role in
ancient Judea it seems that shortly
after writers like Josephus mentions
them the essenes no longer existed in
any major capacity
the Great War with the Romans in 68 A.D
in which Jerusalem and the temple would
eventually be destroyed in the year 70
would have almost cataclysmic effects on
the larger Jewish community
it seems that groups like The sadokies
and the scenes including this group in
qumran did not survive this war and
basically died out as a result
many speculate that it was because of
the approaching Roman armies that the
Quran Community hid all their Scrolls in
the caves surrounding the site and
indeed the text from the qumran Scrolls
include some of the most famous examples
of the so-called apocalyptic literature
the books of Enoch are an incredibly
interesting case which seemed to have
been important to the essenes but which
did not make it into the later biblical
Canon The Only Exception is the
Ethiopian Orthodox Church whose Bible
includes the Book of Enoch and Drew over
on religion for breakfast has already
made amazing videos about both first and
second Enoch so if you're interested in
that topic you should definitely go
check out his videos on that the Dead
Sea Scrolls in general can also be found
in various translations if you are
interested in reading that I highly
recommend it of course if you're
interested in this topic they are
fascinating texts and it's a fascinating
topic to just dive into thanks again to
Andrew for being part of this video if
any of you haven't checked out his
channel religion for breakfast
then what are you even doing you should
go over there right now and subscribe
and check out his content it's some of
the best religious studies content that
you can find anywhere it's really really
amazing and it was an honor to have him
on on this video and now you hopefully
have a better grasp of the context in
which these texts were written and and
read by this community they are
especially connected with this community
in qumran a settlement near the Dead Sea
which by many scholars perhaps most
Scholars today are identified as a group
of so-called essenes reading them
therefore gives us invaluable
information about what appears Tab in a
major movement of Judaism in Judea at
this time and also gives us incredibly
valuable information about second temple
Judaism and the region of Judea and
Israel right at the time of the New
Testament with all this in mind I think
very few would deny that the Dead Sea
Scrolls are one of the most significant
archaeological discoveries of the 20th
century if not of all time
I'll see you next time
[Music]